I was a 18 year old girl with a
mixed-race baby in a pushchair on a
council estate art buyer that was me
because you're doing I've had two babies
they're only 12 you are more dirty when
they have my second child not some
terrible acts of class violence
throughout my life it was a miracle no
one was revealed said one police
commander Risa Mackenzie dr. Lisa
Mackenzie I should say thank you so much
for joining us or undivided and for
those who don't know you for those who
don't know your area of expertise what
do you do I'm a working-class academic
I'm a lecturer I'm a sociologist and the
reason I say working-class academic is
because those two things usually seem at
odds because can you be a working-class
person and an academic I come from a
small mining community Nottinghamshire
called certainly nash field and I lived
there until I was 18 my granddad was a
miner my great granddad was a miner my
dad was a miner my mum worked in the
factories making tights
I'd been told from being a very small
child by my granddad it is me you know
Wheatley so we are working-class we are
good people we keep the lights on you
know we're not like those other people
you know we don't send us kids away
because we don't want them we don't you
know we're not cruel to foxes and
animals you know we were good people
we're keeping the lights on we knew that
we were at the bottom we knew that other
people thought that we were at the
bottom what you know as a young person
growing up there and as a child I
thought we were brilliant and exactly
what does class mean to you
class is a power political structure
it's about relationship so this is what
I found this is a lot of fun out there
going to university what I knew about my
life through experience I knew that this
was happening but when I went to
university I understood that this was a
power relationship this is about the
structure of society you know we hear a
lot about aspiration and nowadays you
know it's the aspiration working-class
people don't have enough aspiration
which is absolutely not true
working-class people if anything has got
too much aspiration because what what do
you mean about that
can one possess too much aspiration
don't you don't you mean by that
actually you know sometimes you reach
exceed your grass well I suppose I would
I would say that is I've got a book and
in this book I'd written when I grow up
I want to be an author I want to write
you know that was not I knew that that
was not really going to happen because
once I got once I was in school that
sort of passion and I had for writing
and just it wasn't ever encouraged it
was you know you go in in the factory
and if you go into scores today kids
want to be doctors and lawyers in
working-class communities the the
reality is that's not going to happen
that's and that's why I say too much
aspiration because there are is a
reality to this it also feeds into sort
of culture and in Britain it's
absolutely ridiculous that we don't
acknowledge it because I teach students
from all over the world
the first thing everybody ever says to
me is a minute you get off a plane in
the UK you noticed this class division
straightaway there it's so noticeable so
we read each other as British people as
we're fast and we read each other we can
talk to each other men you could talk to
each other through the perhaps of the
way that we speak the things that we're
saying no fires that we're pitting oh
yeah we're signifying and when and
that's fine because we do that with
everybody but when you are using that as
a hierarchy and particularly related to
values and morals who is good and who is
bad then that's a real problem because
before you know for working-class people
you are read before you even get in the
room there is also there's all these
things that have been thought about you
before you even get there and that's why
I suppose I always say I'm a
working-class academic because those two
things never go together an academic is
somebody that is learned and read and
intelligent whereas the working-class a
British working-class definitely is not
well let's just take take a look at one
of the examples that you actually use in
your classes at Middlesex University a
figure from the working class that many
people will recognize at Vicky Pollard
it's because you're doing I've had two
babies in there only 12 you are rare
I was 13 when they had my second child
anyway have you've been talking to Aaron
because let me tell you about Aaron
period listen to this no no just listen
I just talked to the face to the hand
they listen because I am feels like a
total body boy
and II got no pubes and he's will avoid
because he's been competing going around
saying I like smoked and drank when I
was pregnant but I like it was pretty
like two packs of five today drink like
50 pints of snakebites no but from that
I never done nothing so you can Welsh
out you should go to Manor you're not in
trouble
you're not in trouble when I show this
to my students my first year students at
Middlesex University mostly oh who are
working-class actually at Middlesex
University when I show this in a
classroom there is a deadly silence
afterwards what was the difference
between okay the character of Vicky
Pollard and for example any of the
characters from the royal family you
know now that which is an example which
people people both working-class
middle-class I've always appreciated and
seen in an entirely different light to
the Vicki [ __ ] item what was the
difference
it's the shadings of class I mean that's
that's the absolute difference isn't it
because the writers were working-class
and they came out from this very
sympathetic view and an experience of
being working-class sitting around
watching television with your family a
lot of love there Vicky Pollard and the
Little Britain stuff has not come from
that it's come from laughing at it's
come from two privately educated man
wealthy very sort of upper middle class
laughing at I mean there's one scene
where Vicky Pollard I mean this is
absolutely disgusting at 13 she's had
two babies or something and it's
supposed to be funny and she swaps one
of her babies for a Westlife CD that is
not funny when you you know when these
stereotypes are constantly all over the
place about you but you mean you
mentioned there that then that the
writers bang the Vicky Pollard sketch
you know we're privately educated that
themselves does that mean that someone
who hasn't experienced our life cannot
write about that life cannot satirize
that like no it doesn't it doesn't mean
that what it means is that there is a
there is a shade and a subtlety between
understanding experi
and laughing at and crossing and I think
we found that with with the sort of the
Jeremy Kyle stuff we finally realized
that this is this is not on I was a 18
year old girl with a mixed-race baby in
a pushchair on a council estate that was
me so I'm I'm critiquing this from very
close up but also I'm an academic
because well I can't deny that I've had
this education so I'm critiquing it from
afar as well so I'm not being
sanctimonious but what I am doing is
that I'm acknowledging that there is a
power difference there and the power
difference is important to people's live
okay what can we do I like I love this
quote from George Orwell which you
probably won't like but and George
Orwell again Eton scholar yeah but had a
very very interesting and Stu
understanding of class in Britain why
because he was part of that
he said when went or the middle class go
to the working class and say what can we
do for you to help you the working class
should say commit suicide because the
fact is is the middle class are actually
soaking up and squatting and in the way
now I'm not saying literal suicide but
what I am saying is you know there needs
to be a debate about who is getting
where and how they are doing it so you
do like a bit class water from time I
love it I'll be honest I love class war
but we explain that expect it's like
that that to be sense that's a slightly
worrying thing you ever know close we're
sitting together but also needs a
explanation no I mean there are many
attributes about being working-class
that I enjoy and some of it is the I
suppose the ology bargee and that their
humor that we have I honestly believe
that middle class people are not funny
I think that working-class people are
funny and so I think when we start
talking about class war there's a
tongue-in-cheek thing about that as well
we can you know we can we can take
people down through humor as well I also
think that these things are important we
have to talk about though I'm like yet
they have to be challenged I protest I
write I get on the streets I talk about
class inequality not because
you know I'm some sort of jealous
working-class woman looking up going if
only I could be this it's actually
because I think it's unfair it's
damaging it hurts people do you think
that the class structure of the class
that the structural issues that we have
in the United Kingdom that stemmed from
class do you think those can be
rectified without conflict and by
conflict I includes violent conflict no
I'll be honest I'll be honest I mean
living through the miners strike and
again you've got to remember my
experience I 60 as a 16 year old girl I
saw terrible terrible violence and class
conflict you know I saw my mum being
dragged across a carpark
by the police and being arrested I saw
my aunties being dragged across the park
carpark the police threw me across her a
car park and told me to go away I was 16
so I've seen terrible acts of class
violence throughout my life Plus that
you know the symbolic acts of class
violence the violence that happens to us
every single day a hundred times you
know the the girl that goes into the
housing office and puts her name on the
list and tries to get a house for and
her children and she is judged
immediately she's walked as she walks in
that happened to me as a 18 year old
girl you know trying to get onto the
counselors list and the woman behind the
counter saying well you know you should
have thought about that before you had
kids violence obviously Pollock violence
that in the circumstances we were
talking about at some point some
revolution be in a revolution of the
mind or a revolution in politics has to
be both I mean it has to be all it has
to be all things we have to we have to
debate we have to talk we have to say
uncomfortable things to each other like
being working-class in Britain is
hurtful and it's damaging people it's
hurting them exerting them mentally and
physically it's hurting the country
nobody's benefiting out of this I've
also taught students that are being the
middle class students are coming through
private education that are being
privately educated almost to death they
come with stress and
or health and that is just so the middle
class can keep their place this it
passed the class system does not benefit
anyone well look at the very least I
hope you know come the revolution you
remember that we invited you on divided
I've discussed it beforehand at least
Mackenzie dr. Lisa Mackenzie thank you
so much for joining us thank you